[Music]
couple of weeks ago I suggested that we
use webcam technology to allow a viewer
at home to sit in our audience virtually
sit here and be present and all we have
to do is set up a laptop here in the
studio and the viewer can be part of our
studio audience without leaving home I
don't think this has ever been
accomplished before no we're gonna be
the first we're trailblazers
there it is right there there's the
webcam I asked viewers to send in a 10
second video 10 seconds telling us why
we should choose them to be the special
extra audience member we got a ton of
responses here are a few of the
finalists Conan I'm 22 I've been
watching since I was 12 and see this
beard right here I've been growing it
since you started this new show if you
pick me I'll shave it off live in the
audience well so basically that's why I
think I should be on your show you
should pick me Santa vasectomy yesterday
Conan pick us we're gonna run over this
beautiful woman and this ripe pineapple
at the Napa Valley Wine Train
I like to watch TV
[Music]
like Cohen I think you should pick me to
be an audience member desk on the camera
because I have a cute dachshund and I
can do this
hi Conan pick me and I'll watch the show
like this
[Music]
I think we have our winner anyway many
of those are coming in will sort through
it to cast your vote for which one of
our dedicated fans should be our extra
audience member go to team koco.com
slash audience plus one
[Applause]